depuis quelques semaines on vous parle
de ses études de l'institut canadien
d'information sur la santé qui dit
essentiellement que les médecins
spécialistes du québec gagne déjà plus
que les spécialistes de l'ontario en
entrevue la présidente de la fédération
des médecins spécialistes du québec dit
qu'on ne peut pas utiliser cette
étude-là parce que l'institut ne compare
pas des pommes avec des pommes dans les
lycées ce n'est pas qu'elles sont
mauvaises c'est qu'elles sont
incomplètes
salefranque hardy essentiellement que
l'institut dans ces études sous-estiment
les revenus des médecins ontariens parce
qu on ne calcule pas les revenus qu'il
tire de la recherche ou de
l'enseignement alors que c'est le cas
pour les médecins spécialistes du québec
lorsqu'on compare la rémunération des
médecins
on n'a pas tous les sources de revenus
dans les autres provinces donc
évidemment on peut pas comparer avec ce
que répond l'institut c'est dans ces
recherches les paiements que les
provinces verse aux médecins pour la
recherche pour l'enseignement ne sont
pas inclus pour aucune province ni pour
les spécialistes de l'ontario ni pour
les spécialistes du québec pour ses
études l'institut dit utiliser les mêmes
critères d'une province à l'autre quand
vient le temps de calculer le revenu des
médecins spécialistes et selon les
calculs de l'institut canadien
d'information sur la santé et les
spécialistes du québec grande déjà plus
que les spécialistes de l'ontario